[Applaudissements]
présidente ministre collègue jamais 203
après avoir gracieusement accorder
quelques jours de débats aux
représentants du peuple madame borne a
dégainé son troisième 49-3 en une
semaine pourtant ça commence bien
c'était la séquence du compromis quand
monsieur Attal nous enjoignait il y a
dix jours à bâtir avec confiance et
responsabilités un PLFSS qui serait
l'une des briques d'un pays plus unis et
plus solidaire c'est beau mais au lieu
de l'unité du pays pour la troisième
fois cet outil brutal de la Cinquième
République fait la preuve éclatante de
votre isolement et de votre minorité
minoritaire à l'Assemblée vous
choisissez de mettre fin à un débat ou
le Parlement veut rejeter votre budget
pour la sécurité sociale minoritaire au
sein du peuple français aussi qui
condamne l'usage répété que vous faites
du 49-3 pour 63 % d'entre eux
car en macronie à 20h on applaudit les
soignants et à 20h01 on sort la matraque
parlementaire pour faire passer un
budget austéritaire
pour sauver l'hôpital public ce
gouvernement doit donc tomber la
macronie aimerait tant qu'on la laisse
camoufler au milieu des dorures de
l'Elysée trier les amendements
acceptables ou non elle rêverait de
pouvoir dans les chuchotements des
conseils de défense porter un coup fatal
à notre république sociale avec ce 49-3
des centaines de propositions sont
balayées d'un revers de la main si vous
ignorez ici les parlementaires
écoutez-les les voix qui monte et que
vous n'avez pas voulu entendre les voix
des soignants des malades des aidants
des retraités des personnes en situation
de handicap des travailleurs et des
pensionnaires des EHPAD des salariés
ubérisés jamais nous ne laisserons ces
voix être étouffées par votre mépris
votre gouvernement est coupable
d'inaction avec ce budget de la Sécurité
sociale et ce 49-3 c'est en réalité une
récidive du fait de l'aveuglement
austéritaire qui vous caractérise
monsieur Attal toujours annoncé dans la
novlan que vous affectionnez tant que
nous ne devons ménager aucun effort pour
trouver des marges déficiences et oui
réaliser des économies là où elles sont
pertinentes c'est un aveu votre
gouvernement est coupable de ces
économies sur notre santé pas un centime
de plus dans ce budget une fois retiré
les hausses de dépenses causées par
l'inflation en macronie c'est le règne
de l'ONDAM coupable de ne pas recruter
suffisamment de soignants alors qu'il en
manquerait déjà 100 000 fautes de payer
décemment et de faire fuir à coups de
Burn Out généralisé ce qui exercent un
métier qu'ils aimaient coupables de la
fermeture de 21 millions
d'hospitalisation tout le monde d'après
ses dents coupable en temps de laisser
les multinationales du médicament gorger
les actionnaires de dividendes à l'image
de Sanofi qui a distribué 4 milliards en
2021 coupable de soutien au patron voyou
d'Orpea avec l'argent public comme un
blanc simple pour maltraiter nos
grands-parents malgré le dévouement d'un
personnel surmené et mal payé votre
second mandat annonce le retour des
hospices publics dans le pays qui furent
en un autre temps le dernier refuge pour
les malades et les aînés quand les plus
riches eux après tout iront se faire
soigner dans des cliniques privées
heureusement pour vous vous pouvez
toujours compter sur vos alliés à
l'extrême droite de cette hémicycle qui
seront là pour soutenir toutes les
exonérations de sécurité sociale qui
plombe les comptes de la Sécu
vous pouvez compter aussi sur Marine Le
Pen qui a défendu l'augmentation du
temps de travail et la fin des régimes
spéciaux de retraite le 49-3 c'est le
porte étendard de cette caste qui
navigue entre les ministères et les
entreprises du CAC 40 cette classe qui
rejette l'état social parce qu'elle
pense pouvoir elle sans passer la loi le
débat la démocratie ne sont pour vous
que les oripeaux d'un temps que vous
voudriez défaire quelques jours de
discussions dans cette assemblée pour la
forme pour l'image pour dire qu'on a
discuté et puis un 49-3 pour tout
balayer alors c'est encombrant le débat
parlementaire c'est encombrant la
représentation du peuple et puis vous
avez pris d'autres habitudes c'était
tellement plus facile de casser
l'assurance chômage par ordonnance
tellement plus facile d'enclencher la
relance du nucléaire sans le moindre
débat tellement plus facile de mettre à
la poubelle les caillettes doléances des
gilets jaunes et les 150 propositions de
la convention pour le climat
ne comptez pas sur nous pour tout
laisser passer c'est le sens de cette
motion de censure n'oubliez pas que
votre gouvernement n'a ni la confiance
du peuple ni celle de cette assemblée
aimez-vous même dans votre propre
majorité de l'effet d'habitude sur
lequel vous comptez tant même les
enfants les plus patients peuvent se
lasser de jouer au Playmobil
les Français méritent mieux et nos
propositions sont prêtes ils doivent
avoir accès à une maternité un service
d'urgence à moins de 30 minutes de chez
eux ou qu'ils habitent sur le territoire
ils doivent pouvoir être soignés quel
que soit leur revenu avec le 100% sécu
ils doivent pouvoir partir à la retraite
à 60 ans plutôt qu'après l'âge de
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé avec
votre CNR santé un énième débat pour
comprendre les mots de l'hôpital public
vous m'évoquez un médecin amnésique qui
inlassablement chaque jour rentrerait
dans la chambre d'un patient pour lui
demander s'il souffre et quels sont ses
symptômes mais il n’est plus l'heure du
diagnostic les faits sont là les
solutions aussi ces propositions comme
des centaines d'autres ne sont pas
discutés ne seront pas débattus ne
seront pas retenus pourtant elle
pourrait être financée et déployée sans
attendre cela ne tient pas à grand chose
une motion de censure un vote
le gouvernement sera hors d'état de
nuire collègue il est temps de dire
qu'un autre monde est possible je vous
invite à voter la censure
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]